you know what evolving means what does
it mean it means you're in a constant
state of perfection and Improvement
right now right right now right now
you're already funnier than you were
just good
[Music]
welcome back to a highly sensitive
episode sensitive why why is it so
sensitive like we have with us Colleen
line art who is
devastatingly emotional hey keep your
woman tears inside which is not that
kind of Channel
how do you know those aren't man tears
man dude that's a sigma male over there
you see this guy he's a what did you
call me a reptile salesman a sing Sigma
Sigma male Sigma chud they say what are
you you look like you just came from
Perth I said you're gonna look like you
were gonna sell us a reptile so I said
earlier all right so there's already a
Crocodile Dundee
I'm I'm alligator Joey alligator Joey is
kind of tight I kind of like that do you
have an Australian accent or a British
accent I gotta keep the looks because
it's still L.A bro
is this contributing to your emotional
shape I'm very emotional why you sad
girl
um I'm sad because Nick is so hilarious
oh Nick is a funny moment he's hard to
measure up to yeah he's so funny he's
very funny I feel like you're being
disingenuous right now and I'm taking it
as disrespect I think you're really
funny thank you I appreciate that she
laughed so hard that she started crying
because Nick made a funny joke I never
knew that there was this type of joy in
the world yup oh this seems like it
seems like you're making fun of me now
you want to hone in on that thing of
Nick being so funny yeah oh the honest
honest thing though if you go on like
certain JK YouTube videos a lot of the
top comments are oh my God Nick is so
funny are we what are these videos thank
you what is this video about I don't
know but it wasn't supposed to be about
this but it's just so compelling I I'm
really not making that up you go to
certain videos this is a really good you
really Blossom Nick thank you I
appreciate that yeah you always wonder
you always wonder you're like why am I
why you choose me
God damn it God damn it this hurts me
and Bart we [__] pick players we do
it's not that it was coveted we needed
to [__] find a person to fill the
seat and you're the only person
available the reason why that sounds
imaginative I don't know dude that's
just what I think okay and if until you
guys could prove me wrong then I'll
forever think that no comments not only
were you a great giggler this guy Not
only was he a great giggler he was a
great contributor yeah you're like I
appreciate that the Chanel West Coast of
JK you got a great laugh you know that
yeah you had a great laugh
yeah do you think do you think do you
think I'm his producer I don't think you
need to be you gotta like Minkus from uh
Boy Meets World what you think you look
like Minkus oh that's what they used to
call Chanel West Coast she kind of looks
like her if you were like yours who
needs looks
it's [__] up it's strong kind of a
back here ugliest nothing but backhanded
compliment he's a front-ended
front-ended front-ended look yeah people
really did say like oh my God Nick is
easily the funniest dude without even
trying on the show like you're the
favorite yeah I appreciate it thank you
I appreciate that I do have to say
though in the beginning a lot of people
were like why do they even have that guy
he doesn't say anything he doesn't
contribute the [__] is the why they have
why they have them there and I'm my word
to you guys is see now you see why
I just want to make my bosses happy
that's all it takes time what's your
secret not talking about this okay
what's the topic of the video this is
crazy this is crazy dude what are you
doing man dude how do you do it everyone
wants to know Shield how do you do it
like if someone wants to come up on
YouTube and be a side character on
another show
can you tell us your success story yeah
how do you do it man
you know what it just because the room
is so great dude it's because of you
guys no seriously oh is this your
acceptance speech no it's just because
you guys are fun so when you when you
guys are fun it creates a silly goose
time and then I feel like if and hold on
if there's any thing I I thrive in it's
a silly goose time dude okay yeah you
guys it's it's all you guys [__] you
dude
how do you compare like your
comfortability between like episode one
to now because I watched episode one
where you came for the first time and I
wanted to see what the dynamic was and
you're so different the first episode I
felt very comfortable and I felt pretty
comfortable but also like
as time went on in like the middle of it
I felt a little uncomfortable why why
did someone make you feel uncomfortable
especially right now a little bit not in
the but not in that video but like like
say like six months into JK I was like
oh like this is inconsiderable now oh
because you thought it was like a
one-time thing
I kept coming back and then but it was
like different people so having to learn
how to like bounce off with different
people in the room because sometimes the
energy is like a little different you
have to kind of like you know figure it
out but also it's just every yeah it's
it's just different okay
what's the last time you guys uh had a
piece of food you hated
where do you draw your sense of humor
from like how do you how do you know
when to say things that you know when
not to say things how do you know when
to have Angry silences how do you know
when to just stare someone down how do
you figure out the timing I don't know
dude that's that's a tough question that
I don't know the answer to if I'm being
honest it just comes natural
no I don't think so I don't know I don't
know this is these I haven't thought
about these answers I didn't know that
this is what this video was a panic
I'm sweating how do you know when like
you know like there's like I think we
might just hear words I thought you're
just setting this guy said so we just
hear a word right we just hear words in
English and like some grammar and stuff
yeah but for you but for you you're like
you hear like
set up
punchline punchline punchline punchline
but how do you hear all the what are you
listening for I feel like you're making
fun of me oh I'm just asking more Ryan
questions no I'm just going by the
comments
like a joke to you brother it's going by
experience he's so funny Nick's so funny
dude stop saying that stop saying that
you didn't need him until you came here
no same with me so I only know this guy
like is he this good everywhere who
knows
we should start seeing him outside of
the JK table but sometimes you know a
lot of the time well I have I actually
never do but I mean hey we hung out last
night
you know what I'm saying to Ryan on her
walk I was like we're walking around and
I was like you know what I had so much
fun hanging out with you guys last night
we should do it more let's do it next
year I should do it yeah we should do it
in a year next quarter we'll do it
[Laughter]
yeah we had such a good like talk after
like during dinner and then like Nick
was like all right guys we gotta go and
everyone was like all right
you're our leader no I just had to go to
I don't wake up to go to work in the
next morning but it's I think
um we should talk about something else
that's what I think what do you suggest
we talk about a funny guy I don't know
wait let me give you an example let me
give you an example okay look look
please tell me I'm not making this up
right on the video on JK about the art
gallery owner that holds down the
homeless person there's a top comment
this is the top comment read that out
loud please
Nick is hilarious wow with the almost
there almost it really says Nick is so
funny man every episode he gets funnier
it's like he's evolving
that's the top comment there you're
evolving why are you read commenting
that's and I just clicked a random video
that's the most insane compliment you
know what evolving means what does it
mean it means you're in a constant state
of perfection and Improvement
right now right right now right now
you're already funnier than you were
just dead
is it just me or Joe and Nick been
getting better with their jokes laughy
face but you know that's actually Nick
because I've been here for freaking over
10 years so it it so you're both I
actually suck we're getting better dude
okay here's let me read this one because
it's really funny don't they say not to
recommend no yes you don't know that's
what YouTubers say this comment is the
top comment above that one it says
something about Colleen and Nick being
on the same side gives off bring your
brother with you energy
bring your brother with you I'm the
sister and I'm bringing my brother to
work look he's like can I go to the ball
and Mom's like bring your brother
[__] come on Nick hey at least my
brother's hilarious yeah
no but yeah these are real that's pretty
cool it's cool that people are saying
that but we shouldn't read comments
somebody said give Nick a raise so he
can eat more exotic food we like it when
he contributes oh oh cause he had a
story about food
I do exotic food bro and Nick I don't
think you're funny I think you're a
bully man [__] you cancer yeah that's
right can't [__] you dude
he heard a setup yeah and he just done
he dunked on it
and I called that Evolution not me can's
giving me a
game one Dynamic where I just get mad at
him and it's you call it a dynamic I
call it pain and suffering
because we're on a video whatever dude
no but that's it's really funny
considering the fact that your main
full-time occupation is technically not
to be funny like you're a very serious
job thank you I appreciate that but you
know when we're working out with people
we're like cracking jokes all the time
we're [__] farting around but for
some reason like you're not even a
professional comedian but you're like
dude this is ridiculous at a social
level which I think arguably is harder
yeah you're being compared to a great
and they're like saying Nick and Joe's
getting better like I just started he
started yeah all right dude we have 10
more minutes what else are we gonna talk
about bro we need ads on this video so
this has to be a good video okay we
can't spend the first 10 minutes talking
about this this is crazy
what's the topic what did you put in the
spreadsheet I don't build the machine
bro if this is what people want that's
what they get nobody said they wanted
this the top comment on the last eight
videos is Nick is getting funnier and
funnier you're over exaggerating every
session we need a nickname we need an
uncomfortable Nick video dude
it's really the funniest part is that
that part's not an exaggeration most of
these videos the top comment is about
you being funnier and funnier thank you
for cherry picking these videos I
appreciate it no but what a comeback
right dude like they used to hate your
ass and they were like what the point of
this fool and now they love them
all he does is just laugh he doesn't do
anything you know if people are
commenting that they go like oh I didn't
know what is this guy doing what's he
why is he here I ask myself the same
question
you don't get one we're in agreeance
so like can how are things with you
catching up with Colleen or can and this
is you're cue to say something
no we were going to talk about Colleen's
love life but dude I want to talk about
Colleen's love this came up and it was
just like totally took over you guys
want to set me on fire when you're so
funny it just overshadows that topic I
just can't it does I will walk on a
traffic right now dude a [__] walk
into traffic what's with you and not
being able to take legitimate praise
yeah
um
what is that what is this a therapy
session
where is that where does that come from
honest honest question honest question
outside of this room on your day-to-day
interactions with people yeah how often
does someone go you you're really funny
man
uh I don't know man does it happen when
you're like at the at the gym doesn't
happen at like tell me how much JK has
changed your [__] life because now
you go out into the streets and then
people are like you're Nick the done
you're Nick they're done your Nick did
some people like rarely some people will
come up and be like oh cool like you're
a JK and I was like
what do you say to that would you say
thank you I I asked their name and I say
thanks for watching thanks for watching
you don't like to take a
I guess I'll
um single file please do people call you
an inspiration they'd be like you know
what the way you deflect you inspired me
like now I deflect like you do I learned
I learned that from Nick I think it's
really cool that like I think first
impression was like when I first saw you
was in photos before like because I was
friends with them and then I saw photos
of this guy and I was like yo he looks
mean that guy looks like he would be
really I'm not mean dude he is mean what
do you think [__] you can that adds to
the feeling of like you're so like fun
and light-hearted and funny and then
juxtapositioned with how like
aggressively mean you could be it's a
breath of fresh air man thank you it's
nice thank you I appreciate that one
you're very nice but you know he is a
brother fresher Nick does smell nice
though cause I'll be [__] doing Jiu
Jitsu and I go your gee smells good bro
oh thanks man I appreciate that that I
appreciate it usually Jiu Jitsu people
smell really oh yeah it's a part of
their defense that's the nicest thing
Joe's ever said about me dude he said my
geese smells nice it does thank you I
appreciate that but when you do your
health coaching do you implement humor
in any of that no I just try to keep it
loose like I'm just talking to somebody
really I thought you're getting fat
jokes ready for your clients you know I
should yeah you'll be like hey you know
why you fat you think that'd be helpful
for business you think that'd be
conducive play it like yo mama TV show
or keep in a safe space hey I'm just
workshopping some jokes so if you don't
laugh just just try it out what were you
guys talking about how JK changed your
life in such a positive and amazing way
we were talking about on our walk we're
saying that how
Ryan was saying how sometimes he'll get
in trouble for like or he'll feel like
he's gonna get in trouble for saying
like all these quickfire jokes and I was
telling him in the real world yeah in
the real world like out in the world
what do you mean like this like uh
because because sitting here and
spending hours just talking and then
just being quick with like how you feel
and just saying it right away yeah out
when you leave this room and you do that
sometimes you catch yourself going like
oh [__] is this not the room people are
accustomed to it yeah yeah yeah yeah
because everyone here slow down and be
playful yeah yeah it might not be and
nobody takes anything like too seriously
you know
are you saying that happens to you
sometimes that happens to me yeah
definitely where I'm like I get a little
carried away with like cracking jokes
and stuff like that and sometimes people
like it goes over their head and they
look at me like oh you're being a dick
and I'm like and then and then one time
Tiff was like no he's joking he's
totally being searched he had to bail
you out your face is still like straight
and then she was like oh okay and like
who are you talking to I was talking to
my sister's friends and she was saying
how like
I think in Mexico City there's all these
like um what's it called
people that aren't from Mexico what are
they called foreigners yes the whites is
what they called them and they're like
oh yeah yeah all these widows coming in
and like gentrifying the area Okay and
then she was like yeah it's like kind of
crazy and and then I said something like
um I forgot what it was but it was
something along the lines of like oh
yeah like no I heard some like the
locals like really are excited about it
like it's like
and then I left and I kept it like kind
of deadpin and I was always like
cleaning dog poop up and I was like
walking around doing it and then she and
I didn't see realize that her face was
like
oh and then tip was like he's joking
he's totally joking and I was like oh
sorry I didn't you know oh but then it
was fine it was it wasn't a big deal but
it was in my head I was like oh yeah
like I I should be a little more that's
the same thing that gets me in trouble
is I I immediately gravitate to the
wrong answer and I love saying it very
confidently because it's so obviously
satirical yeah but not and like not with
everyone else especially if they're
called meeting you they're like that's
his opinion and that was the first time
I met this person so it was like within
the first like that's how he feels about
Amber Alerts
they should shut him off I think they're
being used
honestly I think that's a kidnapper's
best tool
I turn off my Amber Alerts dude because
it vibrates too loud you know dude
that's like if you because you know how
like we joke about like gay stuff in
here yeah but if you did that outside
and then you didn't know that it gets
way more laughs outside and then yeah
and then you accidentally do that and
then you realize oh oh did I make them
feel bad I think it's the worst when you
have gay friends who would make the most
gay jokes and you're so comfortable and
then you say it and then they're like
straight and they get mad at you
I did that the other day actually that's
a really good example because we were at
the uh I was roller skating and I was
making a joke about helmets because like
some people had helmets on and then I
was like yeah it's probably a better
idea to wear a helmet but I mean too bad
I'm not gay and then the dude I was
talking was like you're not right
I was like
yeah I'm not yeah yes I'm gay she just
skate off
your moon walk out there's no right
answer to that yeah at that point you
can't you can't Salvage it like I'm I'm
just gonna say the thing that's like
incorrect because it's funny because
they skate off and do some Twirls yeah
this guy really didn't know if I was gay
or straight but apparently he was like a
little nervous he was a little worried
if you were he's like he skates
counterclockwise